devo lanciare solo questo video quindi
va bene che di vista fa la coca cola non
ci paga neanche per ora questo bevanda
anni e non l'ha capito nessuno né coca
cola scommesso nessuno l'ha capito che
le catene niente perfetto ozpetek e
pieni di stefano vediamo vi auguriamo
che i tutor in coda vinto da sentire
soprattutto buona visione ragazzi
tecnologia la gente ciao non farlo mai
più
stordito così pietro che passa bene
anche dentro merda che la stampa 26
jason non mi attacchi se io sono gesù ti
sguardo anche il cretino animali
domestici cretino proprio allora devi
trovare la batteria e le chiavi dai dai
dai maledizione
capiamo cosa farete quali è una radio
bene la mappa la mappa trota ma no e per
la musica va bene non fa niente
coltellino svizzero benissimo a gettone
da me tu sei appena poche no vai anche
da me
poche palle subire un secondo
solo sei morto e la partita per niente
sulla macchina che da 20 reti
abbiamo le chiavi e la e buster tu
dov'eri giardino o 16 la polizia uno ma
chi cazzo è poi ecco un buon inizio
quanto capito ok abbiamo quattro punti
40 gradi da brizzi occhiali si sa mai
minchia stavi cercando la tanica è vero
ma guarda anche voi sia ok la polizia
manca un pò che non di mezzo la polizia
squadra andiamo nella casa del vicino la
polizia aspettiamo i teatrini ok
sappiamo che abbiamo una missione a
resistere scappare dalla polizia ce la
possiamo fare
lui noi sa dice qui non sai che la
polizia è stata chiamata giusto quindi
in un po minano lo sa cosa ho ok ha
trovato gli altri due vai vai vai ai 395
annunciate ma mai se non ce la facciamo
dobbiamo stare un pochettino distanziati
l'uno dall'altro perché se lui si può
vedere più o meno un gatto da più o meno
il punto dove siamo sono distanziati
credo che questa sia entrata del parco
quindi la polizia si arriva riva qua
praticamente sì ok occhio thai nascosto
finché non arriva da ma cosa vuole stati
ora dove sono un ascolto degli altri due
minuti e 25 ragazzo bk se ci salviamo
con la polizia sarebbe la prima volta
dai siamo tutti continuano le liti
quanti passiamo a finire
ottima cosa ma sono tutti quanti nella
casetta guarda anche se nella carrozzina
seguirla ma perché se degli efficienti
vivete tutti gli era vincola i ricordini
qua guarda per questo mamma ma ok
avevo risolto non venirmi in faccia
qualche brutta frase vai vai su questo
non sono qua siamo troppo visti civetta
ma perché ci seguono che problematici
questi ragazzi tornati a casa ma a vichy
in più ma elevate fracasso se siete solo
inclusione un genio antenore ma chi
cazzo vogliono da me mai io ero lì fermo
questi due minuti accademica ma state
madonna di genova ammazzo non sparavano
gli abiti disfarla ammazzo stai lontano
jason se stiamo vicini ci vede che cosa
vengono invece vicino a me andate via
[Musica]
ma sto bambino stanzino da d'ammazzare
manca molto tranquillo e un commento
manca che ha riferito ammazzo prima
armetta guarda il calendario che
scheinberg andata ammazzo ti giuro
fantoni tv in faccia se ti stai ancora
vicino che faccio io oggi arrivano i 76
5 miglia sanremo gli sparo te lo giuro
vaio si arriva gli sparo dove qua lo so
e dall'altra parte ci credo
no non ci credo non ci posso credere che
ama tanto ma che sa con i [ __ ]
salverà dalla parte opposta
no era la faccia un po sta via via via
di qua via di qua perché vengono tutti
da verde che sono l'unico giocatore di
venerdì 13
l'unico io sono l'unica persona che
gioca bene editrice non ci sono altri
non ce ne sono altri giorni
sono io la gente c'era stai buono tu hai
giocato bene solo pezzo di me tu non
stai giocando gli altri non esistono se
solo palle gioca allora a capo della
mappa magari poi pagina ma la sala morto
e della mamma che fastidio si era
attaccata o il this man porca [ __ ]
[Musica]
che mi siedo sulle sue delle gambe
possenti chiamato fatto miei questo
vieni vieni con i big
scegliete sulle nigger grazie fermiamole
con i due sul server sono più con l'arco
chiamato una padella a posto abbiamo
prima trovare tipo tira le asce cosa va
bene la testa è che scrivi tutto allora
cose simpatiche da fare morire questo
gioco
questo gioco qua è simpatico perché c'è
una persona bruttissima che è commessa
che ripeto è solo memorial isolamento
gli ex altri giocatori che però non
servono quindi seguite stesso tipo itt
cioè con il cosiddetto tutto il tempo
non risulta ferita può sfruttare la
grande differenza è che io no io per
primo salve ti è piaciuto questo salto
ma non può essere tutto il campo e panda
e una di aiuto che kakà è uscito non è
un macigno nato qua perché caga solo me
marca vacca
novecento da casa la maglia nera salvami
ma dove sei tu ma che cazzo ma alquanto
[ __ ] ma lesbica ahia ahia manuali libri
a sofri è schiatta buona pulizia
la schiavone 313 secondo me l'ha preso
si basano praticamente morto cioè non ho
mai sono morto morto famiglie
ecco delitto sì sì sai la chiave chiave
richiami a napoli se non mi viene bene
ma dono mangi stasera c'è tutto legale
chiama caso le chiavi non è mica tre
minuti la polizia posso provare ad
avviarla innanzitutto dove ci scappano
la polizia che credo sia lì però invece
sarà dall'altra parte con ok ci siamo a
open item ha guidato una villa di venire
a prendermi inoltrava mazzo di calcio ci
si becca merde danno a questo non mangia
state picchiate gorgo e gallo e una
preda stasera non mangi poi verso la
libertà dei pezzi di merda
abbiamo vinto abbiamo vinto l'unico modo
per vincere e attendere due minuti la
polizia che arrivi qui quindi è un 50
per cento o qui oli e conoscendomi poi
conoscendomi è solo regionale 300
sbagliati
[Musica]
tu non mangi lo stesso pezzo di m e
zoppicante salvataggio troppi se la mia
perché tra l'altro abbiamo sempre a
tutto a ponente
prendiamo la morte della timara che non
ho mai apprezzato le doti per mattone ma
si potrebbe aspettare chiamante non ci
credo si salva per ogni 0 s'è salvata
va bene sono tutti casi di tutti no
tutti il 2 nociti 2 grazie e non so se
ho fatto la chiusa quindi faccio anche
la juve però che il video vi sia pesce
che sono un padre cerca i ragazzi sono
il video mi piace cavaliere
scusate se sono morto così ma abbiamo
passato una giornata veramente
devastante aprire quella molto bella e
ciglia non possiamo vedere da 100.000
like puoi dire questa cosa
[Musica]